vítej zpět u seriálu Pochopení kvantové informace a výpočtů, jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický ředitel pro vzdělávání v IBM Quantum
toto je 13. lekce série a je to první lekce čtvrté a závěrečné jednotky, která se věnuje kvantovým chybám
opravám kvantové výpočty mají potenciál umožnit efektivní řešení výpočetních úloh, pro které
efektivní klasické algoritmy nejsou známy a možná ani neexistují existují ale velmi výrazné výzvy, které
bude třeba překonat, pokud chceme realizovat typ rozsáhlých kvantových výpočtů, o nichž doufáme, že jednou budou
možné jádrem věci je, že kvantová informace je extrémně křehká – doslova ji můžeš zničit jen tím, že
se na ni podíváš, a proto musí kvantové počítače, aby fungovaly správně, izolovat kvantovou informaci, kterou
uchovávají, od okolního prostředí do krajní míry, ale zároveň musí samotný kvantový počítač poskytnout
velmi přesnou kontrolu nad touto kvantovou informací, a to zahrnuje správnou inicializaci, přesné a spolehlivé
unitární operace a samozřejmě schopnost provádět měření, abychom skutečně mohli získat výsledky
výpočtu je zřejmé, že mezi těmito požadavky existuje jisté napětí, a v počátcích kvantových výpočtů někteří považovali křehkost
kvantové informace a její náchylnost k nepřesnostem i environmentálnímu šumu za to, co nakonec
kvantové výpočty znemožní dnes je jen málo pochyb o tom, že vybudovat přesný a spolehlivý
rozsáhlý kvantový počítač je monumentální výzva, ale máme k dispozici klíčový nástroj, který nám pomáhá v tomto úsilí a který vede většinu
lidí znalých daného oboru k optimismu, že rozsáhlé kvantové výpočty se jednou stanou realitou – a tím nástrojem je kvantová oprava
chyb v následujících čtyřech lekcích budeme diskutovat o kvantové opravě chyb se zaměřením na
základy v této lekci se poprvé podíváme na kvantovou opravu chyb, včetně jednoho z vůbec prvních kvantových
kódů opravujících chyby, který byl objeven – 9qubitového Shorova kódu – a probereme také další základní koncept v kvantové
opravě chyb, který je znám jako diskretizace chyb v následujících lekcích jednotky uvidíme sofistikovanější a v konečném důsledku lepší
konstrukce kvantových kódů opravujících chyby a probereme také problém kvantových výpočtů na zakódované kvantové informaci pomocí
výpočetních komponent, které samy nejsou dokonalé a náchylné k chybám zde je stručný přehled
lekce začneme diskusí o klasických repetičních kódech, což jsou snad nejjednodušší a nejzákladnější typ
klasických kódů opravujících chyby klasické repetice kódy nejsou z hlediska klasické
teorie kódování zvlášť dobrými kódy, přinejmenším ne samostatně, ale to nevadí – zde jde o jednoduchost, a zejména
se podíváme na téměř nejjednodušší klasický kód opravující chyby, jaký si lze vůbec představit, který pak použijeme jako základ pro jednoduchý příklad
kvantového kódu opravujícího chyby tímto příkladem je 9qubitový Shorův kód, který podrobně probereme
včetně popisu samotného kódu, postupů pro kódování qubitů pomocí tohoto kódu, detekce chyb na zakódovaných qubitech a
jejich opravy a ve třetí části lekce probereme diskretizaci chyb, která nám umožňuje přemýšlet o libovolných chybách na
qubitech, jež v principu tvoří kontinuum možností, v diskrétních pojmech – v podstatě redukujeme chyby na
tzv. bit flipy a phase flipy než se dostaneme k technickým detailům kvantové opravy chyb,
stojí za to chvíli se zamyslet nad potřebou kvantové opravy chyb i klasické opravy
chyb jak jsem naznačil na začátku lekce, kvantové počítače jsou vysoce náchylné k chybám kvůli
křehkosti kvantové informace zejména nežádoucí interakce s prostředím, čili
se zbytkem světa, mohou narušit kvantovou informaci tyto nežádoucí interakce mohou způsobit dekoherenci, při níž informace
v podstatě uniká do prostředí, čímž se informace uchovávaná kvantovým počítačem chová stále více
klasicky je také kriticky důležité, abychom si uvědomili, že kvantové operace lze provádět pouze s omezenou
přesností například bychom mohli chtít provést určitý kvantový gate na qubitu, ale protože fyzická zařízení nejsou
nikdy dokonalá, to, co skutečně implementujeme, může být jen aproximace tohoto gatu – to nemusí být velký problém pro
jeden gate, ale pokud chceme provést tisíce nebo miliony kvantových gates, tyto malé nepřesnosti se začnou
hromadit a po skončení výpočtu bychom mohli skončit ve zcela jiném stavu, než jsme
očekávali takže jde o poněkud odlišný zdroj chyb, ale rozhodně je to něco, co nemůžeme
ignorovat lidé studují klasické kódy opravující chyby téměř století a tyto kódy mají mnoho aplikací, například v
přenosu a ukládání informací ale protože klasické výpočetní komponenty jsou tak spolehlivé, ve skutečnosti
nepotřebujeme opravu chyb k sestavení klasických počítačů může se ukázat, že opravu chyb ve skutečnosti nebudeme potřebovat
ani k sestavení spolehlivých rozsáhlých kvantových počítačů například hlavní myšlenka topologických kvantových
výpočtů spočívá v tom, že by mohlo být možné vybudovat robustní kvantové systémy, které jsou přirozeně chráněny před šumem díky
topologickým vlastnostem systémů ale nevíme, zda to bude možné, a je dosti rozšířen názor,
že oprava chyb bude pravděpodobně nezbytná v té či oné podobě pro rozsáhlé kvantové výpočty nyní probereme klasické
repetice kódy, které tvoří základ pro náš první kvantový kód opravující chyby – 9qubitový Shorův kód, který
uvidíme zanedlouho repetice kódy jsou extrémně základní příklady kódů opravujících chyby
myšlenka spočívá v tom, že bity můžeme chránit před chybami prostým opakováním každého bitu určitý počet krát, podívejme se konkrétně na
tříbitový repetice kód zde kódujeme jeden bit do tří prostým třínásobným opakováním bitu, takže
nula se zakóduje jako 000 a jedna jako 111 pokud samozřejmě nedojde k žádné chybě,
snadno rozlišíme obě možnosti, ale pokud nastala chyba a jeden z bitů se přehodil – řekněme
že nula se změnila na jedničku nebo jednička na nulu – stále dokážeme zjistit, jaká byla původní hodnota bitu,
a to tak, že uvidíme, která z obou binárních hodnot se vyskytuje dvakrát – ekvivalentně lze dekódovat výpočtem majoritní hodnoty,
neboli binární hodnoty, která se vyskytuje nejčastěji, a není těžké vidět, že
pokud nastane nejvýše jedna chyba bit flipu, dekódování bude správné pokud se samozřejmě přehodí dva bity nebo
všechny tři, nebude to fungovat a dostaneme špatnou hodnotu při dekódování – to je obecná vlastnost,
kterou má každý kód opravující chyby – možná dokážeš opravit některé chyby, ale nikdy nedokážeš opravit všechny chyby, a nakonec jde
o snížení pravděpodobnosti chyby, nikoli o záruku správnosti, která obecně není
WEBVTT
možná jako příklad situace, ve které můžeme snížit pravděpodobnost chyby, předpokládejme, že naším
cílem je sdělit jeden bit hypotetickému příjemci a k tomu máme možnost přenášet bity přes
tzv. binární symetrický kanál, který každý přenesený bit s určitou pravděpodobností nezávisle převrátí
P takže s pravděpodobností 1 minus P příjemce dostane bit, který jsme chtěli poslat, ale s pravděpodobností P
se bit přehodí a příjemce dostane opačnou hodnotu od toho, co jsme poslali takže pokud nepoužijeme repetice
kód a místo toho jednoduše pošleme libovolný bit, který máme na mysli, přes kanál, příjemce dostane špatný bit s
pravděpodobností p na druhou stranu, pokud nejprve zakódujeme bit, který chceme poslat, pomocí tříbitového repetice kódu a
pak pošleme každý ze tří bitů kódování přes kanál, pak se každý z nich přehodí s pravděpodobností P
pravděpodobnost bit flipu je nyní větší, protože jsou tu tři bity, které se mohou přehodit, místo jednoho
ale pokud se přehodí nejvýše jeden bit, příjemce bude schopen správně dekódovat, takže dostaneme chybu po
dekódování pouze tehdy, pokud se během přenosu přehodí dva nebo více bitů, a není příliš obtížné spočítat, že k tomu dochází s
pravděpodobností 3 * P ^2 - 2 * P na třetí pro hodnoty P menší než 1/12
to vede ke snížení pravděpodobnosti, že příjemce skončí se špatným bitem, stále bude existovat šance na chybu, ale
kód tuto pravděpodobnost snižuje, a pokud bychom chtěli snížit šanci ještě víc, mohli bychom to udělat pomocí
jiného kódu, včetně například možnosti použití repetice kódu, kde se kódovaný bit opakuje
více než třikrát pro hodnoty P větší než 1/12 mimochodem kód ve skutečnosti
situaci zhoršuje v tom smyslu, že zvyšuje pravděpodobnost, že příjemce dostane špatný bit, takže bychom tento kód rozhodně nepoužívali v té
situaci tříbitový repetice kód je klasický kód opravující chyby, ale můžeme se také zamyslet nad tím, co se stane, pokud ho
zkusíme použít k ochraně qubitů před chybami – není to příliš dobrý kvantový kód opravující chyby, jak uvidíme,
dokáže opravit některé chyby, ale jiné chyby dělá pravděpodobnějšími – je to ale první krok k Shorovu
kódu, takže se podívejme, jak to funguje pro qubity nejprve, abychom byli přesní, když mluvíme o 3bitovém repetice kódu použitém
pro qubity, máme na mysli kódování qubitu tak, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce, kde Alpha 0 plus beta 1 je
zakódováno jako Alpha 000 plus beta 111, jinými slovy standardní bázový stav
se opakuje třikrát zvláště poznamenej, že toto není totéž jako trojnásobné opakování kvantového stavu, jako v případě, kdy je daný
kvantový stav s zakódován jako s tensor s tensor s, což není kódování, které bychom mohli
implementovat pro neznámý kvantový stav s z důvodu věty o neklonování kódování, o kterém mluvíme
na druhou stranu, je velmi snadno implementovatelné – tady je velmi jednoduchý kvantový circuit, který to dělá pomocí dvou inicializovaných pracovních qubitů a dvou
controlled NOT gates nyní předpokládejme, že po provedení kódování dojde k chybě
a konkrétně předpokládejme, že na jednom z qubitů dojde k operaci Pauli X nebo jinými slovy k bit flipu
a na tomto obrázku je to prostřední qubit samozřejmě to není jediný druh chyby, která by mohla nastat, a může se zdát
divné, že chyba má podobu této dokonalé unitární operace, ale k tomu se vrátíme později v lekci a prozatím to
můžeme považovat za příklad – tady je výsledný stav, je stejný jako původní kódování s tím rozdílem,
že prostřední bit v každém ketu byl přehozen to je samozřejmě vidět z matematických výrazů pro stav
ale předpokládejme, že bychom měli jen tři qubity a tušili bychom, že mohl nastat bit flip, ale nevěděli bychom, který qubit mohl být
postižen jedním způsobem, jak zjistit, zda nastal bit flip, by bylo provést standardní bázové měření a prozkoumat výsledek – v tomto případě bychom viděli
buď 010 nebo 110 s pravděpodobnostmi závisejícími na Alpha a beta, a v obou případech by byl náš závěr
takový, že prostřední bit se přehodil, ale bohužel to zničí původní kvantový stav a tento stav
může být pro nás cenný – koneckonců celý smysl je chránit tento kvantový stav, takže toto není dobrá
možnost co místo toho můžeme udělat, je použít kvantový circuit zobrazený zde na obrazovce, kde přivedeme zakódovaný stav
do horních tří qubitů – v podstatě circuit vypočítá paritu standardních
bázových stavů pro horní dva qubity a také pro dolní dva qubity kódování, a to odhalí
umístění bit flipu zejména v tomto případě dostaneme pro oba tyto paritní testy výsledek jedna, a z
těchto informací můžeme usoudit, že prostřední bit se liší od ostatních dvou, takže evidentně je to ten, který se
přehodil a zásadně to nezpůsobí kolaps stavu, takže máme nyní šanci pokusit se opravit tento bit
flip, abychom nakonec mohli dekódovat a získat zpět původní stav k opravě se vrátíme
za okamžik, ale nejprve stručně zvážíme ostatní možnosti pro chybu bit flipu – pokud by místo toho nastal bit flip
na dolním nebo levém qubitu, dostali bychom výsledek jedna nula čteno zdola nahoru, a opět
by se stav nezměnil, a pokud by bit flip nastal na horním qubitu, výstup by byl
01 a stav by se opět nezměnil a mimochodem, pokud by nedošlo vůbec
k žádnému bit flipu, výsledek měření je 00 a stav vychází nezměněný
shrňme to tedy ve formě tabulky, kde uvedeme každý z možných stavů, které získáme při nejvýše jednom bit flipu, výsledky měření,
které nazýváme syndromem v kontextu opravy chyb, a opravu, kterou musíme provést, abychom obnovili původní
kódování pokud nedošlo k žádné chybě, syndrom je 00 a nic není třeba dělat,
pokud dolní nebo nejlevější qubit zažil bit flip, syndrom je 10 a odpovídající oprava
je aplikovat X gate na dolní nebo nejlevější qubit a ostatní dva případy jsou
podobné takže pokud aplikujeme odpovídající opravu na základě syndromu, budeme mít jistotu, že obnovíme původní
kódování ve všech čtyřech případech opět bereme v úvahu pouze možnost, že nastala nejvýše jedna chyba
bit flipu to by nefungovalo správně, pokud by se přehodily dva nebo tři bity, a také jsme nezahrnuli
možnost jiných chyb nyní zvažme jiný typ chyby v kvantovém prostředí – bit
flipy nejsou jediné chyby, o které musíme mít starost, například musíme mít starost také o phase flipy
nebo zkráceně jen phase flipy, které jsou popsány Z gates nebo ekvivalentně Pauli Z
WEBVTT
operacemi bohužel tříbitový repetice kód vůbec nedokáže detekovat phase flipy – předpokládejme například, že
qubit zakódujeme pomocí 3bitového repetice kódu jako dříve a na prostředním qubitu dojde k chybě phase flipu
dostaneme stav zobrazený na obrazovce, který je přesně tím kódováním, které bychom dostali, kdyby phase flip
zastihl původní qubit před kódováním, takže pokud provedeme stejný
circuit jako dříve, abychom se pokusili detekovat chybu, dostaneme syndrom 00, který chybně naznačuje, že nedošlo k žádným chybám
takže 3bitový repetice kód funguje pro nejvýše jednu chybu bit flipu, ale nedokáže detekovat chyby phase flipu
ve skutečnosti situaci v jistém smyslu zhoršuje, protože nyní máme třikrát tolik qubitů, které by mohly potenciálně zažít chybu phase flipu
pozorovali jsme, že tříbitový repetice kód je zcela slepý vůči chybám phase flipu, takže se nezdá,
že by byl příliš nápomocný při řešení tohoto druhu chyb ale ve skutečnosti můžeme 3bitový repetice kód upravit tak, aby
chyby phase flipu detekoval, a nyní vysvětlím, jak to lze udělat – tady je původní circuit pro
kódování qubitu pomocí 3bitového repetice kódu a způsob, jakým ho upravíme, je velmi jednoduchý – jednoduše aplikujeme
Hadamard gate na každý qubit kódování Hadamard gate transformuje stav nula na stav plus a stav jedna
na stav minus, takže čistý efekt je, že dostaneme stav zobrazený na obrazovce, kde ket
plus plus plus a ket minus minus minus jsou zkratkovou notací pro tensor tří stavů plus nebo tří stavů minus
chyba phase flipu, neboli Z gate, transformuje stavy plus na stavy minus a stavy minus na
stavy plus takže toto kódování bude užitečné pro detekci a opravu chyb phase flipu, a k tomu můžeme
upravit circuit pro detekci chyb z dříve tímto způsobem: tady je circuit z dříve a co uděláme, je
jednoduše přidat Hadamard gates na začátek i na konec, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce
myšlenka je velmi jednoduchá – první tři Hadamard gates transformují stavy plus a minus zpět na stavy nula a jedna,
provede se stejná paritní kontrola jako dříve a pak druhá vrstva Hadamard gates nás vrátí zpět k našemu
kódování jiný způsob, jak o tom přemýšlet, je, že v podstatě transformujeme chyby phase flipu na chyby bit flipu konjugací Hadamard
operacemi mimochodem, circuit lze trochu zjednodušit – tento circuit je zcela ekvivalentní
a můžeš si to sám ověřit, pokud chceš – takže pokud přivedeme náš zakódovaný qubit do tohoto circuitu za předpokladu,
že nedošlo k žádným chybám phase flipu, dostaneme syndrom 00, což naznačuje, že nedošlo k žádným chybám phase flipu
a pokud máme chybu phase flipu na horním qubitu, řekněme, pak se nejpravější plusy a minusy přehodí
a to má za výsledek jiný syndrom chyby 01 – v tomto případě se identifikuje umístění phase flipu stejně,
jako tomu bylo u bit flipu, a pak ho můžeme opravit aplikací Z gate na horní qubit, a situace
je podobná pro chyby phase flipu na kterémkoli ze dvou ostatních qubitů – takže ve skutečnosti dokážeme detekovat a
opravit nejvýše jednu chybu phase flipu pomocí tohoto kódu, ale bohužel, jak možná tušíš, nyní již nedokážeme
opravit chyby bit flipu vše ale není ztraceno, protože ve skutečnosti můžeme tyto dva kódy
zkombinovat a získat kód, který dokáže opravit jak chyby bit flipu, tak chyby phase flipu, a ve skutečnosti bude schopen
opravit libovolnou chybu na jediném qubitu nyní je čas promluvit o 9qubitovém Shorově kódu, což je kvantový
kód opravující chyby, který získáme zkombinováním dvou kódů, které jsme právě viděli, tedy tříbitového
repetice kódu, který nám umožňuje opravit jeden bit flip, a upravenou verze tohoto kódu, která nám umožňuje opravit jeden phase flip
přesněji řečeno, 9qubitový Shorův kód je kód, který získáme zřetězením dvou kódů, což znamená,
že nejprve aplikujeme jedno kódování, které zakóduje jeden qubit do tří, a pak aplikujeme druhé kódování na každý ze
tří qubitů zvlášť, takže celkem dostaneme devět qubitů – to lze vyjádřit ve formě
diagramu circuit takto: nejprve aplikujeme upravenou verzi 3bitového repetice kódu
který detekuje chyby phase flipu, a pak každý z výsledných qubitů zakódujeme nezávisle pomocí původního
3bitového repetice kódu takže pokud trochu zmenšíme tento circuit, abychom uvolnili trochu místa, můžeme
kód specifikovat poněkud jiným způsobem tím, že popíšeme, jak se zakódují dva standardní bázové stavy pro náš původní qubit
a jakmile to víme, můžeme linearitou určit, jak se zakóduje libovolný stavový vektor qubitu
takže to je 9qubitový Shorův kód a myšlenka spočívá v tom, že jeden z kódů nám umožňuje opravit phase flipy
a druhý kód nám umožňuje opravit bit flipy a jak uvidíme, to ve skutečnosti bude znamenat, že dokážeme
opravit libovolnou chybu na jediném qubitu nyní se podíváme na to, jak lze detekovat a opravit chyby pomocí 9qubitového
Shorova kódu, počínaje chybami bit flipu, které se také nazývají X chyby – tady je circuit, který provádí
kódování a pro snazší diskusi budeme přemýšlet o devíti qubitech, které z tohoto kódu dostaneme, jako o
třech blocích po třech qubitech, kde každý blok představuje kódování, které dostaneme aplikací
druhého kroku kódování, což je obyčejný 3bitový repetice kód – ten se v tomto
kontextu nazývá vnitřní kód, zatímco vnější kód je kód použitý pro první krok kódování, což je v tomto případě upravená
verze tříbitového repetice kódu, která funguje pro chyby phase flipu pro opravu chyb bit flipu
lze každý blok jednoduše zpracovat zvlášť – každý blok je kódováním qubitu pomocí tříbitového repetice
kódu a ten chrání před chybami bit flipu předpokládejme nejprve, že X chyba nastane na kterémkoli z qubitů,
například na prostředním qubitu středního bloku – pokud nezávisle zkontrolujeme každý blok na chyby bit flipu a
opravíme nalezené chyby, bude tato chyba opravena a původní kódování bude
obnoveno ve skutečnosti bychom mohli mít i více X chyb a stále je takto opravit, za předpokladu, že chyby jsou
v oddělených blocích pokud bychom měli dvě nebo tři X chyby v jednom bloku, byl by to problém, ale
dokud je v každém bloku nejvýše jedna X chyba, vnitřní kód je zachytí a budeme schopni obnovit původní zakódovaný
stav takže oprava chyb bit flipu je pro tento kód poměrně snadná musíme ale také uvažovat o phase flipech
nebo jinými slovy Z chybách tentokrát není tak úplně jasné, co máme dělat, protože vnější kód je ten,
který opravuje chyby phase flipu, ale nemůžeme je přímo detekovat a opravit, protože vnitřní kód nějak
WEBVTT
překáží ale uvidíme, jak to udělat, za chvíli abychom lépe pochopili, jak fungují X a Z
chyby a jaké mají efekty uvnitř kvantových circuitů, je užitečné pozorovat několik jednoduchých vztahů mezi těmito chybami a C
NOT gates – to bude také užitečné v pozdější lekci nejprve začněme s X chybami
nebo X gates a jejich vztahem k C NOT gates – pokud aplikujeme X gate na
cílový qubit C NOT a pak aplikujeme C NOT, je to ekvivalentní přehození pořadí a provedení C NOT
nejprve na druhou stranu, pokud aplikujeme X gate na řídicí qubit C NOT a pak C NOT provedeme, nemůžeme jednoduše
přehodit pořadí, ale místo toho musíme aplikovat X gate na oba qubity, a všechny tyto vztahy si
můžeš sám ověřit, pokud chceš, přemýšlením o tom, co se stane se standardními bázovými stavy – situace je podobná pro Z
chyby s tím rozdílem, že role řídicího a cílového qubitu se přehodí – konkrétně pokud provedeme
Z gate na řídicím qubitu C NOT a pak provedeme C NOT, má to stejný efekt jako provedení
Z gate po C NOT ale pokud provedeme Z gate na cílovém qubitu místo toho, je to
ekvivalentní nejprve provést C NOT a pak aplikovat Z gate na oba qubity, a konečně všechny tyto
vztahy jsou symetrické v tom smyslu, že vždy můžeme přehodit pořadí gates na obou stranách každé rovnice
což je ekvivalentní inverzi nebo konjugaci obou stran, přičemž X, Z a C NOT
gates jsou svými vlastními inversemi nyní zvažme phase flipy a jak je detekovat a opravit
pomocí 9qubitového Shorova kódu – tady je náš circuit pro kódování a budeme nadále přemýšlet o devíti
qubitech použitých v kódování jako o třech blocích po třech qubitech – předpokládejme, že Z chyba nastane na
kterémkoli z qubitů, například na tom zde označeném – pomocí toho, co jsme právě pozorovali o Z
gates a C NOT gates, je to ekvivalentní dvěma Z chybám před C NOT, jedné na
řídicím a jedné na cílovém qubitu, a tyto chyby se náhodou komutují s druhým C NOT v bloku, takže
můžeme přehodit pořadí a tady je to, co dostaneme – dolní Z chyba nic nedělá, protože působí na stav nula,
a zbytek lze posunout a dostat tento diagram – takže jsme zjistili, že Z chyba někde uvnitř
středního bloku je ekvivalentní Z chybě na prostředním qubitu před druhým krokem kódování, a
totéž lze odůvodnit pro Z chybu na kterémkoli z qubitů – phase flip na kterémkoli qubitu v bloku
je ekvivalentní phase flipu na odpovídajícím qubitu před vnitřním kódováním, a to je vlastně docela přímočaré a intuitivní, pokud
přemýšlíš o tom, jak Z chyby ovlivňují tříbitový repetice kód – takže jednou možností, jak se vypořádat se Z
chybou, je dekódovat vnitřní kód a pak detekovat a opravit Z chyby pomocí vnějšího kódu, což je upravená
verze 3bitového repetice kódu, která dokáže opravit Z chybu – to opraví naši Z chybu a
pokud bychom chtěli, mohli bychom znovu zakódovat vnitřním kódem – Z chyby lze také opravit
přímo, takříkajíc, bez dekódování a opětovného kódování, a je to docela přímočaré, ale abychom vysvětlili, jak to
udělat, budeme potřebovat trochu více prostoru – předpokládejme, že dekódujeme vnitřní kód
a pak spočítáme syndrom pro vnější kód pomocí stejné metody jako dříve, kde zahrnujeme pouze tři qubity z vnějšího kódu a
pak znovu zakódujeme – no, lze trochu zjednodušit všechny tyto C NOT a vlastně
použít vztahy mezi NOT gates a C NOT gates, které jsme právě pozorovali před chvílí, abychom s tím pomohli
a tím ušetříme čtyři C NOT a toto je circuit, který dostaneme – pokud nastala Z chyba na jednom
z qubitů, syndrom nám nyní neříká, který qubit zažil Z chybu, ale v jakém bloku Z chyba
nastala – to je ale v pořádku, protože víme, že nezáleží na tom, který qubit v bloku zažívá Z chybu –
efekt je stejný pro všechny tři qubity v tom bloku, a tak ve skutečnosti dokážeme opravit Z chybu aplikací Z gate na kterýkoli z
qubitů v tom bloku – to je mimochodem příklad toho, čemu se říká degenerace v kódu
opravujícím chyby, kdy jednoznačně neidentifikujeme danou chybu, ale přesto ji dokážeme opravit – a konečně předpokládejme, že nastane jak
bit flip, tak phase flip, možná na stejném qubitu – například předpokládejme, že
bit flip a phase flip nastane na tomto konkrétním qubitu – ukazuje se, že tyto chyby mohou být
detekovány a opraveny zcela nezávisle, a ve skutečnosti nezáleží na tom, zda opravíme každý blok nejprve na
bit flip a pak na phase flipy, nebo naopak – abychom to pochopili, nejprve pozorujme,
že pořadí těchto chyb nezáleží, takže je můžeme přehodit, pokud chceme – důvod pro to není ten, že by
X a Z komutovaly, protože nekomutují – X * Z je rovno záporné Z * X, ale
faktor minus 1 nemá v této situaci žádný efekt, protože jde o globální fázi – Z chybu nyní můžeme přesunout stejně jako
dříve, a v tuto chvíli je evidentní, že pokud bychom nejprve opravili každý blok na X chyby a pak opravili
Z chyby, obě chyby bychom opravili – alternativně, pokud bychom se z nějakého důvodu
rozhodli nejprve opravit Z chyby, mohli bychom to udělat a X chyba na tento proces nemá vůbec žádný vliv
to musí být pravda, protože zaprvé X chyba komutuje s každým gate v circuitu, který počítá syndrom
pro vnější kód, a zadruhé pořadí mezi X chybou a Z gate, který aplikujeme pro opravu,
nezáleží, stejně jako jsme argumentovali, když Z gate byl chybou – to umožňuje opravu Z
chyby a pak můžeme opravit každý blok, abychom eliminovali X chybu – takže jsme argumentovali, že
pomocí tohoto kódu dokážeme opravit X chybu, Z chybu nebo obě na kterémkoli z qubitů
ve skutečnosti dokážeme opravit více chyb, například více X chyb, pokud spadají do různých bloků,
nebo více Z chyb, pokud alespoň jeden blok dostane lichý počet z nich – ale do budoucna bude nejrelevantnější
to, že dokážeme opravit X chybu, Z chybu nebo obě na jakémkoli qubitu, a v poslední části lekce
uvidíme, jak to je ve skutečnosti dostatečné k závěru, že tento kód dokáže opravit libovolnou chybu na jakémkoli
qubitu než přejdeme k poslední části lekce, ve které budeme uvažovat o libovolných kvantových chybách, stručně
zvážíme výkonnost 9qubitového Shorova kódu, když na qubitech náhodně nastávají chyby reprezentované Pauliho maticemi
WEBVTT
abychom byli konkrétnější, zvažme jednoduchý model šumu, kde chyby nastávají nezávisle na qubitech
s každým qubitem, který zažívá chybu s pravděpodobností p, bez korelace mezi chybami na různých
qubitech nejhorší případ pro 9qubitový Shorův kód je, že Y chyba, neboli jak X chyba, tak Z
chyba, nastane na každém postiženém qubitu, a budeme předpokládat tento nejhorší případ jen pro účely získání hranice
na výkonnost kódu, ale mohl bys uvažovat například také o tom, že tři Pauliho chyby jsou stejně
pravděpodobné – nyní předpokládejme, že Q je qubit v nějakém konkrétním stavu, který chceme chránit před chybami, a představ si, že
máme možnost použít 9qubitový Shorův kód – měli bychom ho použít? odpověď není nutně
ano, protože pokud je šum příliš velký, neboli p je příliš velké, Shorův kód by ve skutečnosti mohl situaci zhoršit,
stejně jako jsme měli pro repetice kód, když p je větší než 1/2, ale pokud je p dostatečně malé, pak
odpověď je ano, kód bychom měli použít – podívejme se tedy, proč je to tak a co znamená, že p je příliš velké nebo dostatečně malé
pro tento kód – Shorův kód dokáže opravit jakoukoli Pauliho chybu na jednom qubitu a v nejhorším
případě, kde jsou Pauliho chyby Y chybami, to znamená, že kód úspěšně chrání Q s pravděpodobností danou
výrazem zobrazeným na obrazovce – konkrétně kód funguje, když nedojde k žádné chybě, a to nastane
s pravděpodobností 1 minus p na devátou, protože existuje devět qubitů, z nichž každý musí být nepostižen, a funguje, když nastane
přesně jedna chyba a s ohledem na to, že existuje devět různých qubitů, které mohou být postiženy, nastane to s pravděpodobností 9 * P * (1 - p) na osmou
na druhou stranu, kdybychom se neobtěžovali kódem, náš jediný qubit by nebyl postižen chybou s
pravděpodobností 1 minus p, takže kód pomáhá pouze tehdy, když je první pravděpodobnost větší než druhá
protože tyto výrazy reprezentují naše pravděpodobnosti úspěchu ve dvou případech – když kód používáme a když ho
nepoužíváme – tady je graf těchto dvou funkcí pro malé hodnoty p a zjistíme, že bod vyrovnání nastává přibližně při
asi 3 a čtvrt procent – takže pokud je p menší než tato hodnota, kód
pomáhá – v bodě vyrovnání jsou pravděpodobnosti stejné, takže jen zbytečně plýtváme časem spolu s 8 qubity,
ale jinak to nijak neškodí – a nad tím bodem bychom rozhodně neměli tento kód používat,
protože ve skutečnosti zvyšuje pravděpodobnost chyby na zakódovaném qubitu, který v tomto kontextu obvykle označujeme jako
logický qubit, a to se děje jednoduše proto, že pravděpodobnost dvou nebo více chyb na devíti qubitech je
větší než pravděpodobnost jedné chyby na jednom qubitu pro hodnoty p v tomto rozmezí – 3 a čtvrt procent se nemusí zdát příliš
skvělé, zejména ve srovnání s 50 %, což je analogický bod vyrovnání pro tříbitový repetice kód pro
klasickou informaci, ale je těžší chránit kvantovou informaci, a navíc ačkoli toto
kódování představuje brilantní objev jako vůbec první kvantový kód opravující chyby a je skvělý pro pedagogické účely, faktem je
to, že z praktického hlediska není zase tak dobrým kódem – dosud jsme uvažovali o X chybách
a Z chybách v kontextu 9qubitového Shorova kódu – nyní uvažujme o libovolných chybách
počínaje nejprve unitárními chybami – taková chyba by mohla například odpovídat velmi malé
rotaci Blochovy sféry, která možná reprezentuje chybu způsobenou nedokonalým gate, nebo
by to mohla být jakákoli jiná unitární operace na qubitu, a to nutně nemusí být něco blízkého identické
operaci – mohlo by se zdát, že oprava takových chyb je obtížná – existuje nekonečně mnoho možných chyb tohoto druhu
a je nepředstavitelné, že bychom mohli přesně identifikovat, jaká chyba nastala, a pak ji vrátit zpět – ale
ve skutečnosti nemusíme dělat nic jiného, než co jsme již probrali – pokud dokážeme opravit bit flip, phase flip nebo oboje, pak ve
skutečnosti uspějeme v opravě libovolné unitární chyby na jednom qubitu a nyní vysvětlím, proč je to
tak – nejprve, jako všechny matice 2x2, lze libovolnou unitární matici
reprezentující chybu na jednom qubitu vyjádřit jako lineární kombinaci čtyř Pauliho matic, včetně identity
a mimochodem, jak si mohl všimnout, používám velká X, Y a Z k označení Pauliho matic bez identity
a budu tak pokračovat po zbytek tohoto seriálu – to je konvencí v kvantové opravě chyb a také
trochu usnadňuje čtení v tomto kontextu bude také vhodné používat dolní indexy k označení toho,
na který qubit daná unitární operace qubitu působí – takže například pokud použijeme Qiskit's
konvenci číslování qubitů začínající od qubitu nula napravo, pak máme výrazy zobrazené na obrazovce pro
různé unitární operace na jednotlivých qubitech, kde v každém případě tensorujeme unitární matici s maticí identity
na každém jiném qubitu – konkrétně tedy můžeme vyjádřit UK, tedy U aplikované na qubit K, jako stejnou
lineární kombinaci jako dříve, s tím rozdílem, že každá Pauliho matice je aplikována na qubit K – dolní index pro identitu
nemusíme uvádět – jde o to, že toto je identita na všech
qubitech – nyní předpokládejme, že SÍ je 9qubitové kódování stavu qubitu – pokud chyba U nastane na
qubitu k, dostaneme UK * SÍ, což lze vyjádřit jako lineární kombinaci Pauliho operací působících na SÍ, což je
samozřejmě jen SÍ v případě identity – nyní bude užitečné pozorovat, že Pauliho Y
matice je rovna i * X * Z, takže tuto substituci v našem
výrazu provedeme – tato chyba nastala a nyní předpokládejme, že se ji pokusíme opravit pomocí stejného postupu jako
dříve – prvním krokem je spočítat syndrom, který je v případě Shorova kódu 8 bitů dlouhý – dva bity pro každé ze
tří použití vnitřního kódu spolu s dalšími dvěma bity pro vnější kód – ale to vlastně nezáleží, můžeme o tom přemýšlet jen jako o
řetězci pevné délky – tady je popis stavu, který dostaneme bezprostředně před měřením syndromu, kde každý
syndrom je libovolných osm bitů, které dostaneme z odpovídající Pauliho chyby – v tuto chvíli si všimni, že tyto dva
systémy jsou obecně korelované, a to je ve skutečnosti klíč k tomu, aby to celé fungovalo – měřením syndromu
efektivně kolapsujeme stav do takového, kde jedna ze čtyř Pauliho operací byla aplikována na K-tý
qubit SÍ, a ze syndromu budeme vědět, která Pauliho operace to byla, takže ji můžeme opravit,
pokud je třeba – konkrétně, pokud změříme syndrom a provedeme odpovídající opravu, dostaneme stav ve
WEBVTT
formě zobrazené na obrazovce, která je zásadně produktovým stavem – máme původní nepoškozenou zakódovanou verzi jako
pravý tensorový faktor, což je to nejdůležitější, a vlevo máme matici hustoty s, která
popisuje náhodný syndrom chyby, ale již neexistuje žádná korelace se systémem, o který nám jde, což je
ten napravo, protože chyby byly opraveny – v tuto chvíli můžeme qubity syndromu zahodit nebo je resetovat
pro případ, že je chceme použít znovu, a to je vlastně dost důležité, protože právě takto se z systému odstraňuje náhodnost nebo entropie
generovaná chybami a právě takto funguje diskretizace chyb, přinejmenším pro unitární
chyby – v podstatě měřením syndromu efektivně projektujeme chybu na chybu popsanou
Pauliho maticí – na první pohled se může zdát příliš dobré na to, aby to byla pravda, že dokážeme opravit libovolné unitární chyby
takto – dokonce chyby, které jsou nepatrné a samy o sobě sotva znatelné – ale důležité si uvědomit je
to, že jde o unitární chybu na jediném qubitu, a díky návrhu kódu nemůže operace na jednom qubitu změnit stav
logického qubitu, který je kódován – vše, co může udělat, je posunout stav mimo prostor platných
kódování, ale opravy ho vrátí přímo tam, kde byl – a konečně zvažme, co se stane,
když nastane libovolná, ne nutně unitární chyba – nastavení je stejné jako dříve
zakódovali jsme jeden qubit do 9 pomocí Shorova kódu a na jednom z qubitů nastane libovolná chyba reprezentovaná kvantovým kanálem
jak uvidíme, vše bude fungovat v podstatě stejným způsobem
jako u unitárních chyb, a prvním krokem k ověření tohoto je zvážení Kraussovy reprezentace naší
chyby – co nyní můžeme udělat, je postupovat přesně stejnou úvahou jako pro unitární chyby, s tím rozdílem, že tuto úvahu
aplikujeme na Kraussovy matice místo na jedinou unitární matici reprezentující chybu
konkrétně každou Kraussovu matici lze vyjádřit jako lineární kombinaci Pauliho matic, a to nám umožňuje
vyjádřit působení této chyby fí na libovolný qubit K, na který působí, ve formě zobrazené zde na
obrazovce – vše, co skutečně děláme, je rozvinutí Kraussových matic jako lineárních kombinací Pauliho
matic – pokud pak spočítáme a změříme syndrom chyby a opravíme jakékoli odhalené chyby, dostaneme
podobný typ stavu jako v případě unitární chyby – nebudu procházet detaily, je to všechno dost podobné unitárnímu
případu a trochu nepřehledné na zápis, ale konceptuálně je to docela
přímočaré – měl bych zmínit, že toto vše se zobecňuje na jiné kvantové kódy opravující chyby, včetně kódů, které mohou opravit chyby na více
qubitech – v takovém případě lze chyby na více qubitech vyjádřit jako lineární kombinace tensorových součinů Pauliho
matic a odpovídajícím způsobem různé možné syndromy budou popisovat opravy prováděné na více qubitech místo jen jednoho
qubitu – ale základní myšlenka je přesně stejná – opět měřením syndromu
efektivně projektujeme nebo kolapsujeme chyby do diskrétní sady možností reprezentovaných tensorovými
součiny Pauliho matic, a opravením těchto chyb – tedy Pauliho chyb – dokážeme obnovit původní
zakódovaný stav – mezitím veškerá náhodnost generovaná v procesu je přesunuta do qubitů syndromu, které pak můžeme
zahodit nebo resetovat, což je zásadní, protože právě takto je entropie generovaná chybami a měřeními syndromu
odstraněna ze systému – a to je konec lekce, ve které jsme se poprvé podívali na
kvantovou opravu chyb, včetně 9qubitového Shorova kódu a diskretizace chyb – doufám, že se připojíš k
další lekci, ve které budeme diskutovat o stabilizátorovém formalismu, který nám poskytuje výkonný nástroj pro popis a
analýzu velké a zajímavé třídy kvantových kódů opravujících chyby, včetně těch, které jsou slibními kandidáty pro
skutečné kvantové počítače – nashledanou